[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the former nfl quarterback heisman
trophy winner at usc carson palmer
joining us on the program where are you
right now
i am in las vegas nevada
doing what
uh tomorrow night i am going into the
college football hall of fame so there's
a
banquet
event all kinds of fun stuff going on
here in in vegas who gets thanked first
when you go into the hall of fame
that's a good question i i think family
when you say
family it's very blanket yeah it handles
kids it handles parents it handles
wife it handles brothers sisters cousins
aunts uncles so i think you when you
throw out the blanket it handles
everybody
how much luck goes into winning a
heisman
uh a lot of luck and and really just
timing i mean you watch what bryce did
uh against the the alabama defer against
the
the georgia defense and we haven't seen
anybody do that all season long and and
watching bryce do that yesterday
uh
i mean 400 yards multiple touchdowns and
he made that georgia defense look really
really average and and you just don't
see that
against a georgia bulldog defense like
we've seen all season long so i think i
think bryce won it yesterday yeah or
saturday yeah i agree
you have to have that heisman moment and
that was a heisman moment
what was your heisman moment
my heisman moment was against uh
was against
notre dame
at home
uh in los angeles on the coliseum floor
i think notre dame was three maybe four
uh there were one lost team i think they
were ranked three or four in the country
we were ranked four or five
uh and and beating
beating notre dame throwing for 400
something yards throwing for three or
four five or touchdowns that that was my
heisman vote
i got you 425 and four touchdowns
against notre dame
that was it i mean that that's the thing
is it's such a momentum award and now
that we have the playoffs and now that
we have the opportunity to see
bryce play against the best of the best
and then again
uh for two more games hopefully the
alabama crimson tide are still playing
for two you know two more weeks
uh of the of the the championship week i
think that's what you need right now i
think the the voters i got my uh you
know as a voter you get
an email you get multiple you know uh
things in the mail and i've been holding
off i've been waiting to watch alabama
play against against
the george bulldogs and and that's the
game i've been waiting for before i
voted and now that i saw that game
that's that's where my vote my number
one vote is going is to price
yeah i i'm the same way i i'm a voter
and i just wanted to see if he had a a
stand-alone game where he
because
you can give him credit or blame in how
the auburn
game finished because he didn't do
anything for 59 minutes and then did
something and then you know they went in
overtime
so you can kind of pick and choose there
against georgia you know there's there's
no argument there he was great from
start to finish
it's the best defense we've seen in
you know five or ten years and at the
college football level
so so to watch him come out and play
you know they were down metchy you saw
meche go down early with the hamstring
early you know whatever that issue was
number one target goes down and he still
continues to play and produce and put
the numbers up so you know i think it
was a huge moment it was a big a big win
obviously for the alabama crimson tide
but more importantly
for bryce i mean that that was a heisman
winning weekend
is there any downside to winning a
heisman
no
no i'll never forget i was i was you
know 19 or 20 years old whatever i was i
went into norm chow who was my offensive
coordinator at usc
uh and and i was getting ready to get on
a plane to fly to new york and
i was excited about it i was i was
you know i was anticipating going to new
york for the first time
on somebody else's dime staying in a
nice hotel
you know limo service all that and then
i went into norm chow's office and norm
was like hey
this is the moment where your life
changes this is the moment where
everything is different from here on
and i remember hearing that and i was
getting ready to fly on like a tuesday
and i think the the event was on a
saturday and i remember hearing that and
thinking that you know obviously norm
knows what he's talking about he's he's
been there he's done that
and then i went to new york i won the
heisman and
and from there on
no matter what you do in the nfl no
matter what you do thereafter you're
always known as a heisman trophy winner
and he
norm chow was spot on when that moment
we were talking about kenny pickett's
fake slide in the pit game against uh
wake forest in the acc title game okay
is it
what did you think of that play first of
all
you can't do that i mean it's it's bush
league you know you as a quarterback and
whether you're in the nfl or the college
level as soon as you give yourself up
the play's over as soon as you say all
right i'm taking myself out of this play
i'm turning into a third baseman i'm
sliding into third
the play is over as soon as you do that
the play is over and i i think
there's going to be a lot there's going
to be a lot of changes from here on
um but as soon as you give yourself up
and you say that the play is dead and
you go into that slide the play's over
and and they need to blow the whistle
what do you mean changes are gonna
happen
well i mean i i
you know i
my i think second or third year in the
nfl
i had a guy dive directly into my knee
in a playoff game blow my knee out and
from then on it was called the carson
palmer rule and then it later was called
the tom brady rule and then it'll
probably be the patrick mahomes rule or
whoever that is that
uh that is that his knee is blown blown
out by one individual player on one
individual play
you know i i think that that'll change i
think every every
ump will go into the off season they'll
watch the film they'll see it they'll
talk about it they'll decide it's kind
of like when you saw it in the nba as
soon as guys started faking charges
all of a sudden you started seeing fake
charges get called i think you're gonna
start seeing that
uh at some point because college
football has got to change that as soon
as you give yourself up as a quarterback
or as a player and and the play's over
the whistles blown you move on to the
next play that that that will change i
think this offseason do you wish it was
still called the carson palmer
play
i do i do but i get it i mean brady's
tom brady and and when you saw his knee
get get blown out that season end for
the patriots
it made a lot of sense why it was called
the brady rule why are we almost
fighting the urge to give brady the mvp
or have him as the leading candidate
nothing about it makes sense i mean the
guy's almost 50 years old
none of it makes sense
the numbers he's put up me through four
touchdowns yesterday against a really
good uh in atlanta against a really good
atlanta defense that is doing everything
they can to stop tom brady and he just
finds a way to throw three four five
touchdowns every week it's amazing
yeah and you keep looking at what he
does you know godwin had what 12 or 14
catches and evans and even fournette out
of the backfield
this is you know tom's not taking his
five-step seven-step he's just it's out
quickly
and it just even if you know what's
happening he's still able to you know
complete the mission here
yeah that haymaker's coming and and
everybody knows it's coming and no
matter what you do to block it and
protect yourself he consistently throws
three four five i mean he's gonna throw
40 touchdowns at 40 years old which for
a quarterback that played in the nfl a
long time ago that's 40 years old i
understand just how impressive that is
and maybe he gets to 50 maybe they win
another super bowl it just it it's one
of those things that just no matter what
that next
milestone is
they are all impressive it's like when
you're playing golf and you get older
and can you shoot your age
you know when when somebody is 72 and
they want to shoot a 72 like tom brady
44
wanting to have
44 touchdowns at least i mean that's
it's pretty amazing and and it doesn't
seem like it's going to end any and
there's no reason for it to end anytime
soon
no none of us want it to we all kind of
do we want to see at some point
you know that
that patriot dynasty and now uh what's
going on in tampa you want to see it
slow down you want to see that kind of
you want to see patrick mahomes take
over that dynasty you want to see
whoever the next young tyler murray
whoever it is but at the same time i
mean you've everybody's got to be blown
away by this what what we're seeing week
in week out
it's it's mind-boggling none of it makes
sense the guy's almost 50 years old
still doing it at the mvp level and and
he might end up winning it and and
that's that might be what we need to see
as fans is the guy that's 44 win the mvp
to go okay this guy is the greatest all
time because i feel like there's a lot
of people kind of on the border and
don't really want to give him that
credit of the goat of the greatest of
all time
it's done he won it he's the greatest
quarterback in the history of the league
and we're just
continuously seeing week after week him
reach new milestones he's carson palmer
former nfl quarterback going into the
college football hall of fame tonight in
las vegas what did you make of the
ravens going for two
to try to win the game in pittsburgh
it's a rivalry game you know and i know
everybody wants to you know you know put
a bullseye in the back of harbaugh
at the end of the day when you're
talking about the nfc or the afc north
those two divisions are so difficult to
win they're so difficult week in week
out
you know i i love it i love the
aggressiveness i love them saying you
know what we're going we're going to win
this game or we're not on this one play
and not playing for overtime
regardless of what's going on in
pittsburgh regardless of what's going on
in ben roethlisberger's career at the
end of the day i love it and
unfortunately that one didn't work out
um but they will work out over time for
harbaugh
you imagine if the uh patriots win
tonight
that because it feels like we're very
begrudging and giving belichick and the
patriots the credit they probably earned
as one of the better teams in the afc
because we don't really know anybody on
that team other than mack jones and he's
a rookie
i think they win you know i i think they
win i think that stigma of getting past
belichick and getting past new england
to be
the creme de la creme of that division
it's hard to get to and and i know
everybody wants to jump on the the josh
bandwagon and and he's spectacular he's
you know he's got the arm he's got the
legs he's got he's got everything you
want as a player but at the end of the
day
that division goes through new england
and they're not giving it up mac jones
may be a rookie he may be in you know
his his first year under belichick's
uh under belichick's control but at the
end of the day i think that team wins i
think new england wins and i think
they're still the best team in that
division is tony romo going into the
college hall of fame tonight
he is
yes
is he there
uh i'm sure he is i haven't seen him yet
i think he's i think he just got done
calling a game last night at midnight uh
and is probably on his way to vegas okay
are you worried his speech might be a
little more animated or you know he
might
you know he might have the telestrator
out
you know what he's going to do romo is
great at predicting he might be
predicting what you're going to do
before you do it
he might predict my speech which
that would suck if i got out there and
said the same speech that romo just said
about myself that would
suck are you going to gamble while
you're there
i did last night it didn't go great
do you still have the heisman
uh
you you shipped it to me but i don't
have the key to open the box it's in
this big beautiful crate this big
beautiful you know bank vault looking
box and i don't have the key somewhere
the key is somewhere in the mail i'm
hoping
so i have a nice big box
oh no
that the heisman is in the in the box i
will tell you that it is there
i hope so it's heavy yeah it's certainly
heavy but i don't i need the key oh no
do you
do we know who sent that damn thing out
to
it's the one of the guys in the back
yeah paulie you said make sure you dan
no
you said you were going to take great
care i did i closed that suitcase
because i wanted to make sure like you
know his his hand wasn't sticking up and
then we bent his finger or anything like
that
i closed the case and then we locked it
damn isn't there a key that works in
this in all of those heisman cases
i i think there's a heisman key okay um
i got
i got a different key i didn't get the
heisman key i got a key but i don't have
that key so maybe baker mayfield kyle
murray maybe one of those guys will send
me a key i'm hoping
oh man i'm embarrassed you were nice
enough to let us have well borrow the
heisman
and i wanted to make sure it got back to
you for this big moment
we'll figure it out no i'm sorry about
that
do you want to fire somebody
can i fire somebody i'd love to hire
somebody i i went to the tables last
night blackjack was not hot i'm a little
bit pissed off still is there anybody
there i can fire yes see well there's
never back tomorrow i'm getting messages
in my ear but people are already firing
off blame and say no it's mario but
actually technically dylan did it but
then it was mario who said to eric to
sue the thing so
[Music]
it also could have been a problem with
the actual mail whether it's fedex ups
whatever you call it because i got a
photo was sent to me from the college
football hall of fame showing the case
and then there was an envelope that had
a little tear in it that was attached to
the case that the key was supposed to be
in and somehow there was a little tear
where the key was either taken or it
fell out of the envelope
damn
this this is a developing story carson
that i've got to get some of my best
people on this
yeah put them on it
they uh typically those keys those
little teeny tiny keys don't come up
at the fedex facility or the ups
facility
but
if i can fire somebody that would make
me feel so much better
um i got a guy mclovin who's a lame duck
who's going to leave right before fire
mcnovin i'm not firing mclovin i love
mick webman oh my god
yeah polly can you display a heisman
case on your mantle when people come
over trust me my heisman's in there
there's a lot of
just put it up there you got a strong
mantle don't you carson to that idaho
house
i've got a i've got a big heavy hearth
that you can put that case on and it's a
gorgeous case there's no doubt about it
so
yeah i think you're right
i think you just say trust me that my
heisman is in there it's in it it's in
it all right i'm gonna work on that and
see if we can find the key
to your heisman
that's embarrassing you know you would
have thought that we would have lost the
heisman and you would have gotten the
key
but it's the other way around
typically that's how it works but you
know what
like i said i'm sorry i'm i'm you know
i'm hopeful i think it'll show up at
some point if it doesn't show up i've
got a big gorgeous case
have fun tonight don't let romo out
out speech you because it feels like he
might be fired up ready to go
oh i mean he loves a camera and a
microphone there's no doubt about that
yeah i'll be in the back i'll be waiting
to i'll be i'll be scanning
the casino floor looking for the right
table looking for the right dealer
looking for the right seat that's all i
need is one good shoe all i need is one
good shoe
uh have fun tonight and uh thanks for
joining us
thanks dude that's carson palmer
what what the hell is going on around
here did we ship the case and a piece of
paper with a key tape to the side no we
had an envelope
taped to the side aka piece of paper
yeah
i closed the heisman case and i i locked
it and that was it i just wanted to make
sure that that it got in there